المترجم: Yomna Elhaddad
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
(تصفيق)
حديث اليوم سيتكلم عن بحث قمت بإجرائه
مع بروفيسور سورياداس.
عن حل لمعضلة داخل النسبية العامة
تعرف بمتفردة الإنفجار العظيم.
البحث بمنتهى البساطة
يطرح سؤالاً ويجاوب عليه.
هل للكون بداية؟
بالطبع، هذا يتمحور
عند دراسة علمين في الفزياء،
علم الCosmology وعلم فيزياء الكم.
معنى علم الCosmology هو دراسة علم
الكونيات.
أو علم دراسة تطور الكون
بالطبع حتى نتكلم عن الكون وعن تطوره،
إذن لابد أن نبدأ بالقصة بداية من نيوتن
تبدأ القصة مع نيوتن بمحاولة فهمه
لقوة أساسية في الطبيعة
تُسمى بالجاذبية.
عندما نزلت عليه التفاحة بينما هو جالس،
بالطبع لا أعلم إذا كانت أسطورة أم حقيقة.
لم يأكلها إنما سأل،
"لما نزلت هذه التفاحة
على الأرض بهذا الشكل"
نقضه أنه صاغ قانوناً عاماً باسمه
"قانون الجذب العام لنيوتن".
لو لديك أي كتلتين مختلفتين
أو أي كتلتين موجودتين.
يحدث بينهما قوة جاذبة، أي كتلتين.
مثل الأرض والشمس، مثل التفاحة والأرض
مثل أي كوكبين أو أي كتلتين
موجودتين في الطبيعة
لكن عندما أتى نيوتين، حاول أن يقيس
الزمن الذي تأخده الجاذبية،
حتى تنتقل من هذه الكتلة إلى تلك،
وجد أن الزمن يساوي صفر؛
بمعنى أصح تنتشر الجاذبية
انتشاراً آنياً في الفراغ،
أو تنتشر إنتشاراً آنياً بلا أي وقت.
لا يوجد زمان مطلقاً.
لاحقاً بعدها بفترة كبيرة،
أتى إينشتاين واقترح النسبية الخاصة.
النسبية الخاصة مبنية على مبدأين أساسيين؛
أول مبدأ:
قوانين الفزياء واحدة عند أي نقطة
في هذا الكون.
عند كل نقطة في المكان والزمان،
هذا هو المبدأ الأول.
المبدأ الثاني، هو ما أحدث تغييراً جذرياً
لنظرتنا في الفيزياء.
أنه افترض أن أقصى سرعة في الكون
هي سرعة الضوء،
ليس هذا فحسب،
هي السرعة التي لو رصدتها
بأي شكل ستظل ثابتة.
ما معنى هذا؟ وما اختلافه
عن الميكانيكة العادية؟
نحن نعلم أن في الميكانيكا العادية
أو في ميكانيكا نيوتن
لو أنت تسير مثلاً بسيارة بسرعة 30 كم،
وشخص آخر يسير بسيارة بسرعة 50 كم،
في الساعة على سبيل المثال.
عندما تأتي لقياس سرعته
وأنتم في نفس الإتجاه،
كم ستقيسه؟
20 كم/س، طرح 50 كم/س من 30 كم/س.
الذي قاله إينشتاين:
"لو افترضت أن هذا الذي يتحرك،
يتحرك بسرعة الضوء،
والتاني الذي يرصده يتحرك بنصف سرعة الضوء،
عندما يرصده هل سيرصده بنصف سرعة الضوء
أم سيرصده بسرعة الضوء نفسها؟"
سيرصده بسرعة الضوء نفسها؛
فسرعة الضوء مهما تغيرت حالتك
وأنت متحرك، ثابت،
مهما تغير شكلك ترصدها كما كانت،
لا تتغير.
هذا الفرض قاده في سياقة
النسبية الخاصة لتنبؤات.
مثل تمدد الزمن، ماهو تمدد الزمن؟
فرضاً أن عندك توأم مثلا، يعيشان على الأرض،
قررنا أن أحدهم سيعيش على الأرض،
وجعلنا الثاني يركب سفينة فضائية،
بسرعة V مثلاً أو بأي سرعة.
الرجل الذي ركب سفينة الفضاء بسرعة معينة
وسيرجع بنفس السرعة.
بحيث إن السرعة تقترب من سرعة الضوء
يعني أنها ستكون كبيرة جدا.
لو رجع بعد فترة حتماً حسب تمدد الزمن.
سيكون أصغر من أخيه، لماذا؟!
في هذه الحالة نحن مفترضون
أن الزمان والمكان مزيج واحد.
فأي زيادة أو أي سرعة تفعلها
في الزمان والمكان،
يؤثر في الزمن الخاص بك.
ويؤدي إلى عملية تُسمى بتمدد الزمن.
بالطبع هذا تم إثباته تجريبياً
ليس خيالاً علمياً.
قمنا بإثبات هذا الكلام تجريبياً
على مستوى حتى الجسيمات الأولية.
لكن هناك تعارض رئيسي بين نظريتين،
نظرية نيوتن التي تقول أن الجاذبية تنتشر
بلا وقت يعني سرعتها لا نهائية.
وما بين النسبية الخاصة التي تقول أن أقصى
سرعة في الكون هي سرعة الضوء.
نحن في حاجة إلى أن نجد
عملية توافق ما بين النظريتين.
وهذا ما عمل عليه نيوتن لمدة عشر سنوات.
من 1905م إلى 1915م .
ما هذه النقطة سنعطيكم مثالاً
حتى نقرب لحضراتكم الأمر:
تلف الأرض حول الشمس،
لو افترضنا... بالطبع ضوء الشمس
يصل إلى الأرض، في كم؟
في 8 دقائق.
يأخد الضوء 8 دقائق حتى يصل إلينا.
لو فرضنا أن الشمس اختفت من مكانها،
في هذه الحالة، ستشعر الأرض
أو ستخرج من مسارها
-من المدار الخاص بها-
في نفس اللحظة؟
أم ستخرج عن المسار بعد فترة معينة؟
حسب قوانين نيوتن ستخرج في نفس اللحظة،
لأن الجاذبية تنتشر انتشاراً آنياً بلا وقت.
حسناً، أتى أينشتاين ليعالج
هذا الأمر وقال:
"الآن أريد حل المشكلة ما بين
أن سرعة الضوء هي أقصى سرعة
وما بين الجاذبية الخاصة بأينشتاين
تنتشر انتشار آني
بمعنى أنها بلا وقت.
يعني من المفترض أن الجاذبية تنتشرعلى
الأقل أو على الأكثر بسرعة الضوء.
ما الذي يجب أن يحدث ليحدث هذا؟
كي تختفي الشمس وتترك الأرض
مكانها بعد 8 دقائق؟
إذن، لا بد من الزمنكان أن يحدث له تموج.
هل معنى هذه الموجة أن الزمنكان
أصبح مسطحاً أم منحنياً؟
أصبح ينحني،
الزمان والمكان أنفسهم
وليس شيئاً ينتشر عليهم.
بل الزمان والمكان بأنفسهم ينحنون.
يأخذ هذا الإنحناء 8 دقائق من اختفاء الشمس
حتى يصل إلى الأرض.
فلو افترضنا أن الشمس اختفت،
سنشعر أن الأرض ستخرج
عن مسارها بعد 8 دقائق.
لكن هذا معناه أن مفهوم إينشتاين للجاذبية
اختلف جذرياً عن مفهوم نيوتن.
اعتبرها نيوتن قوة، قوة طبيعية أساسية
موجودة في الطبيعة.
تنتشر انتشاراً بسرعة لانهائية.
أينشتاين قال لا!
إنها إنحناء في الزمان والمكان.
لديك إنحناء في الزمان والمكان،
إذن لديك جاذبية.
حسناً، هذا الفيديو يوضح
لحضراتكم إختفاء الشمس،
أترون هنا التموجات أو الأمواج المنتشره؟
تحتاج 8 دقائق حتى تصل إلى الأرض
وتحركها من مكانها،
أو تحركها من مدارها.
هل تم اكتشافه تجريبياً؟ بلى.
وأعتقد أن جميعنا سمع بالاكتشاف
الذي حصل من إسبوعين
عن اكتشاف موجات الجاذبية
نتيجة تمازج للثقوب السوداء
وتم قياسه في تجربة مباشرة.
جميل،
فبالتالي أينشتاين فهم الزمنكان
على أنه نسيج،
تستطيع أن تتخيله كالمطاط.
لو لديك كتلة كبيرة،
سيحدث لهذا المطاط انحناء
حول هذه الكتلة الكبيرة.
لم تعد مسطحتاً بعد الآن.
هذا معناه، أنك لو تحركت بعيداً
عن إطار الجاذبية
ستتحرك بشكل مسطح.
إنما عند تحركك بالقرب من الجاذيبية،
ستتحرك في خلفية منحنية أو بشكل منحني.
هذا بالطبع غير ما تعلمناه
ونحن بالصف الأول الإبتدائي.
شيء مثلا كالضوء ينتشر في خطوط مستقيمة،
هذه كلمة غير دقيقة علمياً.
لو عندك مجال جاذبية،
سيمشي الضوء في خطوط منحنية.
حسناً!
هل كانت هذه الفكرة ناجحة في توصيف الفزياء؟
نعم!
قبل إنتشتاين كان العلماء
عاجزين عن تفسير
حركة مثلاً كحركة عطارد،
بمعنى أن كوكب عطارد وفقاً لقوانين نيوتن.
أتت النسبية العامة ونجحت بالكامل
في تفسير هذا؛
إن مدار عطارد يتغير مع الزمن
أو يسافر مع الزمان.
مرة يلف حول الشمس هكذا
ومرة يلف هكذا ومرة يلف هكذا.
هذا التفسيير...
النظرية الوحيدة القادرة على شرحه،
هي النظرية النسبية العامة لأينشتاين.
هناك أمر آخر تنبأ به أينشتاين
وقيست تجريبياً،
انحناء الضوء في الفراغ.
لو افترضت أن هذه مثلاً مجرة،
والذي في المنتصف كتلة كبيرة في الفراغ،
وهذه هي الأرض حسب...
وهذه المجرة خلف الكتلة.
من قوانين نيوتن:
من المستحيل أن ترى هذه المجرة نهائياً.
إنما في قوانين أينشتاين ينحني الضوء
نتيجة مجال الجاذبية.
فيمشي منبعجاً بهذا الشكل.
هل تم قياس هذا تجريبياً ؟ نعم
قام العالم إيدنجتون بقياسه تجريبياً.
حسناً!
نستطيع تلخيص كل هذا في معادلة بسيطة،
أو معادلة... عملية فكها بالطبع...
لكن المفهوم الخاص بها جميل.
جانب اليد اليمنى وجانب اليد اليسرى،
جانب اليد اليمنى هو عبارة عن...
لو لديك كتلة، لو لديك طاقة،
لو لديك كمية حركة على الجانب الآخر
سيسبب هذا إنحناءً في الفراغ.
هذا بمنتهى البساطة
المعادلة الخاصة بأينشتاين
الخاصة بالنسبية العامة.
لكن بالطبع، أي نظرية لديها العيوب،
أو التعارضات الخاصة بها.
لقد قلنا في البداية أن نظرية أينشتاين
مبنية على ماذا؟!
على أن قوانين الفيزياء
صالحة للتعريف بشكل متفرد،
عند كل نقطة في الزمان والمكان
في هذا الكون.
لكن عندما آتي لأحل معادلات أينشتاين
وأرى أنها تنهار،
وقوانين الفزياء نفسها تنهار
عند نقاط محددة في الكون،
وتصبح تلك نتيجة تتعارض مع المبدأ الأساسي
الذي بُنيت عليه النظرية.
تُسمى هذه المشكلة في الفزياء
"Physical Singularity".
ترجمتها باللغة العربية:
"المتفرده الفيزيائية"
وتُعتبر مشكلة في البناء
أو في التركيبة الخاصة بالنظرية
هذا الكون كما ترون...
بمعنى أصح قوانين الفيزياء،
أنها من المفترض مثلما هي على الأرض،
مثلما هي على عطارد، مثلما هي على الشمس،
مثلما هي في مجرة أندروميدا في أي مكان.
القوانين هي نفسها،
القوانين صالحة عند كل نقطة
في الزمان والمكان.
لكن النظرية النسبية العامة لديها مشكلة،
إن بعض الحلول فيها تتعارض مع هذا المبدأ،
الذي بُنيت عليه.
والذي أثبت هذا هو العالم
بنروز والعالم هوكينج
العلماء الإنجليز...
أثبتوا أن في العادة...
وأمر مشهورة جداً
أن نقطة بداية الكون نفسها،
نقطة غير فيزيائية.
تنهار عندها قوانين الطبيعة.
وهذا يتعارض مع البناء الخاص
بالنسبية العامة،
الذي يقول أن قوانين الطبيعة صالحة للتطبيق
عند كل نقطة في الزمان والمكان.
فعندما درسوا الإنفجار الكبير،
ما هو الإنفجار الكبير؟
إن تتخيل أن هذا الكون مثل البالون،
نتيجة مثلا أنك...
لقد وجدنا رصد عملية رصد
أن هذا الكون في حالة توسع تام.
لو قمت بعمل تتبع للوراء
أي رجعت بزمن هذا الكون.
من الفترض أن يحصل له إنهدام عند ماذا؟
عند نقطة محدده.
من المفترض أن هذه النقطة تكون فيزيائية؛
بمعنى أن تنطبق عليها قوانين الفيزياء.
عندما درس بنروز وهوكينج هذه النقطة
وجدوا أنها غير فيزيائية.
نقطة تنهار عندها الفيزياء،
تنهار عندها قوانين الفيزياء،
لدينا شيء اسمه: متفردة الإنفجار العظيم.
النقطة البداية التي في الأسفل،
نقطة تنهار عندها قوانين الفيزياء.
حسناً، بمعنى أصح اسمها نهاية ميتة.
لما حاولوا تفسيير ذلك؟
تفسيره أنهم قالوا أن النسبية العامة
مبنية على شيء اسمه مبدأ الحتمية،
أو على مبدأ الفيزياء الكلاسيكية.
ما معنى الحتمية؟!
يعني أن يصبح لديك مسار، مسار محدد.
لو عرفت الشروط الإبتدائية لهذا النظام.
تقدر أن تتنبأ بسلوكه بشكل حتمي.
فلدى هذه المسارات حتمية أنها تلتقي
في نقطة واحدة وتتركز
وعندما يحدث هذا،
تتكون لك المتفردة الفيزيائية.
فهذه تمثل لك نهاية يعني
أن تموت الفيزياء هناك.
هل الإنفجار العظيم هو الشيء الوحيد؟
لا، هناك حلول ظهرت في النسبية العامة
تتعارض أيضاً مع الشرط الذي بُنيت عليه.
مثل الثقوب السوداء؛
الثقوب السوداء أيضاً تُشكل متفرده
تفشل أو تنهار عندها قوانين الفيزياء.
هذا مثلاً لو أردنا أن نتخيل
التمدد الخاص بالكون.
سنقوم بعمل تتبع للوراء في النقطة البيضاء
على جانب اليد اليسرى،
هذا ما نسميه بمتفردة الإنفجار العظيم.
متفردة الإنفجار العظيم
حيث تنهار جميع قوانين الفيزياء،
والتي نحاول حلها.
لكن حتى نقوم بحلها...
كانت هذه الفكرة الخاصة بالبحث الذي أجريناه
مع بروفيسور سورياداس.
إننا عند هذه المسافة الصغيرة،
من المفترض لقوانين فيزياء الكم
أن تكون هي المسيطرة
حسناً، ما هي قوانين فيزياء الكم؟
وحتى تستخدمها لابد من استخدام شيء يسمى
بالـQuantum Trajectory
أو المسارات الكمية بدلا من المسارات
الكلاسيكية
لأن المسارات الكلاسيكية بشكل حتمي
تلتقي وتكون هذه المتفردة.
حسناً، ما العمل لو اعتبرنا
المسارات الكمية مكانها؟!
في هذا الحالة...
لابد من أن أعرف حضراتكم
ماذا يعني مسار كمي؟
ماذا تعني فيزياء كم؟
كل ما عرفته في الحياة اليومية الخاصة بك.
فيزياء الكم عكسه تماماً.
بمعنى أصح، في الفيزياء الكلاسيكية
أو في حياتك اليومية.
لو طاقتك مثلاً تساوي 20 حصاناً،
وأمامك حائط
وحتى تقوم بتكسيرها تحتاج إلى 1000 حصان.
حتى يحدث هذا،
من المستحيل كلاسيكياً أن تقدر
على اختراق الحائط.
هذا ما نسميه بالقوة.
بفيزياء الكم يصبح ممكناً
لو طاقتك أقل من قوته،
بإمكانك تجاوزه ببساطة.
لماذا؟
نتيجة مبدأ يُسمى بمبدأ اللاحتمية.
الذي هو Δ x Δ p ≥ ℏ
الℏ هو ثابت والΔ x
هو ال الموقع وΔ p الزمن
ما معنى هذا؟
هذا مبدأ لا حتمي،
إن العلم الحديث مبني على مبدأ عدم الحتمية
ماذا يعني مبدأ عدم الحتمية؟
لحظة من فضلكم.
إن المسار الحتمي الذي كان موجوداً
في الفيزياء الكلاسيكية.
في الحالة الكمية،
من الممكن للجسيم الكمي أن يأخد عدد
لا نهائي من المسارات في نفس الوقت.
طب هل هذا متفق مع الفكرة الكلاسيكية؟
بالطبع لا، إنها ناقضة تماما.
لو تخيلنا أن فيزياء الكم تلك
تعيش على شيء نستطيع أن نراه...
هذا مثال لشرودينجر مشهور جدا
وهو معناه،
أنك... من الممكن أن تكون موجوداً.
في حالة الحياة وحالة الموت في نفس الوقت.
هذا لو فرضنا إن قوانين فيزياء الكم
يمكن مشاهدتها
على مستوى النطاق الواسع الخاص بنا
تجربة مشهوره مثل Double Slit
أو عملية التداخل؛
الجسيم الكمي هنا يأخد هذين المسارين
في نفس الوقت.
هل يمكن لك حتى أن تتخيل هذا بعقلك؟
هل يمكن تخيل ذلك من خلال
الأطر الكلاسيكية التي نعرفها؟
بالطبع مستحيل!
إنما بفيزياء الكم هذا ممكن.
حسناً، ما هي فيزياء الكم؟
إنها بالأساس، أساس العلم
لكل العلوم الحديثة؛
علم الفيزياء الذرية، علم الفيزياء النووية
علم فيزياء النانو
كل هذا مبني على فيزياء الكم
على مبدأ عدم الحتمية.
كان هذا يجاوب حتى على كلمة أينشتاين
هل يلعب الله بالنرد؟
نعم، يلعب الله بالنرد حسب ميكانيكا الكم.
هنا، لو طبقنا مبادئ فيزياء الكم
على نقطة البداية وهي الإنفجار الكبير،
ما الذي يمكن أن يحدث؟
فائدة مبدأ اللاحتمية أو عدم التأكد
يقول لي:
إن المسارات الكمية نتيجة عدم الحتمية...
من المستحيل لمسارين كميين أن يتقاطعوا
أو يتركزوا في نقطة واحدة.
عندما أتينا لتطبيق هذا المبدأ
على هذه النظريات
تستطيع ان تقول عنها المسارات الكمية،
على المستوى الكمي، على المستوى الصغير
على مستوى الطاقات العالية جدا
أو المسافات القصيرة جدا
لديك عدد لا نهائي من المسارات
لكن من المستحيل لهذه المسارات أن تتقاطع،
أو تتركز في نقطة واحدة.
بالطبع، هذا يعالج مشكلة تكون المتفرده
التي اقترحها هوكينج واقترحها بنروز.
فبالتالي لو طبقنا هذا على نقطة البداية
في هذه الحالة،
من الممكن للبداية نفسها أن تكون فيزيائية.
لكن فيزيائية طبقاً لقوانين الكم.
هذا كان شكل الكون أو شكل تطور الكون
في الحالة الخاصة بنا.
هذا المنحنى الأحمر والذي هو كلاسيكي
أو ما نقول عنه أن لديه متفردة
هذا المنحنى الأزرق يقول:
"حتى تقيس الزمن الخاص بالكون
تحتاج إلى زمن لا نهائي"
وهو أبدي وليست له بداية مطلقة.
بشكل عام أو في استنتاجنا الخاص
الزمنكان هو متفردة بشكل فيزيائي،
تنهار فيها الفيزياء.
عندما نستبدل المسارات الكلاسيكية
بالمسارات الكمية.
نجد أن هذه المتفردات تُعالج.
باعتبارها نجد أن...
وتطبيقها على تطور الكون،
نجد أن الكون على المستوى الكمي...
لأن الآن لا يوجد بداية مطلقة.
على المستوى الكمي لا يوجد بداية مطلقة
لو اعتبرنا الQuantum Trajectos.
أو المسارات الكمية.
نجد أن الكون ليس له بداية.
بالطبع نشرنا هذا الكلام في مجلة
Physics letters.
شكراً لحضراتكم.
(تصفيق)